اخوتي واخواتي الكرام عدنا لكم من جديد من
هنا من ارض الشمال معكم عبود في اخر
التطورات يا اخوان الزنانه ما بتعرفش لا
سيف ولا شتاء ولا اي حاجه 84 ساعه بتزن زي
امي يعني امي بحكي لها ياما حر عدس ياما
شتاء عدس صيف عدس ايش موضوع حتى ها اسمع
بتزمر قاعده 16 16
المهم يت يا اخوان تتذكروا لما ابو عبيده
كان حاكي انه الاصر في غزه بياكلوا نفس
ماحنا بناكل معقول هق طبخ لهم طنجره عدس
بس البصل غالي يا
عم ينصر دينا المهم وال يعين الناس اللي
في الخيام زي ما انتم شايفين انا مش قادر
اتحمل السقعه مش عارف هم كان متحملين ها
الله يعينهم ويكونوا بعونهم يا الله وربنا
ينصرنا
ويثبتنا ومش ع يعني شوفوا الناس هدول مش
عاملين
على السطح ل را دار كلها
محروقه تلزقش الدار اعمله على السطح فربنا
يكون بعونهم والله يثبتنا وينصرنا على قوم
الظالمين هدول قوم الظالمين هدول بدنا
قديفه الياسين لما تيجي بيهم بدهم ي قديفه
الياسين 107 شي
اكبر
l